when I was starting to play there wasn't
even I think in Boston and Berkeley was
one of the very few places where you
could actually not even sure if you
could major in guitar you know guitar
was it's like you know well yeah you can
play the guitar but you have to play a
real instrument if you're gonna get a
degree or something
and I played clarinet in college you
know when I first went to college I
majored in clarinet because they
wouldn't let me major in guitar and I
mean all that's changed now and that and
there weren't you know there was North
Texas State and Berkeley just a couple
places that had jazz programs and that's
definitely changed and there's so much
available so much music you can get in
books and it's all around but there's
something even when I mean my generation
it's still I had to kind of learn by
going you know I'd go to clubs and older
guys would let me play and a lot of it
was happened outside of school you know
what in that I'm thankful that I was
able to and the generation before that
was even more you know we're there you
just learned on the in a bar or
something that's where you learn how to
play but and that doesn't seem to happen
I don't know I guess it's still there I
don't know and I'm glad that all this
stuff is available but there's there's
something
I think you can't just go one way you
have to try to get as much as you can
get from as many different directions
like if you just go into a school I
think the danger is just to go into a
school and stay within that I mean
there's a lot in there if there's you
can spend your life just right in there
but there's a lot of other stuff outside
of there and I think dangerous is just
staying closing off whatever else what
other other ways there are to learn
about stuff like the thing about go to a
college and then end up teaching at the
college and then UT you know this sort
of incestuous I think starts happening
and I'm not sure how healthy that is I
think there's laws against
I just recently have gotten to play a
little bit with Jason Moran a piano
player he's not that young but he's
someone within the last few years that I
heard that like I heard something in his
music that sometimes I almost get afraid
that there's I heard some sort of I
can't explain what it is but something
that I hadn't heard for a long time that
goes way way back way away deep into
some place way far back and everyone's
why I get afraid that these things are
getting lost some times and I heard him
and I was like okay everything we're
safe that things are I love his music so
much and and to get to play with him was
really great recently I heard another
piano player from New Orleans
Jonathan batiste who's he's young and
his band was you know they're some of
the guys in a band were not even 20
years old yet I just heard them a few
months ago and I heard something in that
music that again it was this emotional
heart
it wasn't about that he I mean he's a
fantastic technical player but it that
wasn't well what was getting me was he
was tapped into this emotional thing
that gets me going when I listen to
music and he was working with that and
that really gives me hope that I mean
music there's no way we're gonna kill
music there's a like to be somebody
that's gonna get it